when I was little I used to love when my
family would order Chinese takeout but
now that I'm older I can make it myself
so I'm making a homemade broth with
chicken bones pork bones shrimp shells
and large green onions I simmered this
for six hours and I know that's a lot if
you don't have the time then bouillon
cubes or box broth is fine then for the
wontons we need ground pork and minced
shrimp seasoned with oyster sauce soy
sauce fish sauce and garlic powder and
then mix to combine you want to buy The
Wonton skins that are made specifically
for soup because these will be thinner
and taste a lot better pinch the
opposite Corners together fold the
remaining sides up and then pinch to
close
add the white parts of green onions
Ginger soy sauce fish sauce and white
pepper to the broth bring to boil and
then let it simmer for 15 minutes and
then in the meantime boil the wontons in
a separate pot since you're going to
release a lot of starch